learning to use technology
isn't just cracking the code of a
complex computer program
it's cracking the code of the world that
we live in
understand why we see this instead of
that's
while we hear this instead of that
so we must all get the right digital
skills
so to all of you
happy eu code week
we all work all student computers
we drive cars
and stream tv series and film thanks to
millions offline codes
we tend to forget
but everything in digital technology
starts with a line of code
being able to understand it
to write it in a meaningful sequence
is truly the superpower of the 21st
century
and those who participate in eu code
week take a first step
to acquire this skill
always striving for the best
is part of the dna of european culture
and heritage
europe
needs a skills revolution
and the code week can be an important
contribution to our jam to the digital
age
do not miss this opportunity to become
creators
not just passive consumers of digital
technology
if you always wanted to trade coding
then eu codeweek is there to help you
get started
and i like to encourage both girls and
boys to improve their digital skills
create content rather than consume it
and be ready for the world of tomorrow
i've been involved in the creation of a
coding school
called fit for coding some years ago
getting these digital skills has proven
invaluable
for getting a quality job
by participating in the european code
week you are one click closer to acquire
and master a new language a global
language that you can pass on and teach
around you
technologies are what we make of them
you can become actors of change in a
world more connected and more green
[Music]
you